pornhub released their uh year in review
data ooh
this is good top search results from
different states and different countries
do they have bottom search results as
well yeah
this is top search results from around
the globe okay 2021 oh i love this all
the united states is ebony let's [ __ ]
go morocco wow morocco is anal
wait what
morocco's number one search result is
anal
dub yep dudes there it goes that makes
sense okay canada you got lesbian hey
look at india staying true yo where
where's india india is indian oh [ __ ] yo
that's actually that's on brandon
stay true
that's what's up all right africa's
ebony yeah except until you get to the
north then it's lesbian
oh wow arab they like lesbian yeah that
kind of makes sense though right oh no
arabic
that country right there that middle one
what is that algeria or something i
think so yeah that's tunisia that's
algeria
and then what is this all of like
eastern nobody asked what tunisia was
ain't nobody asked what tunisia was like
you know
just trying to flex and [ __ ] happen
ain't nobody asked
can we talk about that
yeah that's a lot and brazil russia
loves hentai bro yo what is hentai
brazilian [ __ ] that's cartoon [ __ ]
oh
i thought that's anime but when anime is
[ __ ] is hentai
oh
yeah
when animes aren't [ __ ] it's just
anime it's just anime yeah oh that's
what's up why do
british colonies love lesbian porn so
much
i don't know canada australia i think
that's just where chicks are watching
porn and most chicks watch lesbian porn
ah
the most liberated
female countries that's my assumption
are gonna have women who also watch porn
and that disrupts and they watch lesbian
porn because that's the only porn that
is made to pleasure the women exactly in
the porn yeah so this is not a true list
i mean it is no it's not oh yeah it's
not just the men in the country we only
care about what men are watching i mean
nobody goes i wonder what women are
watching in porn
just find out what the men are watching
i don't know how i feel about the fact
that pakistan's number one is in india
as well this is by state this is
texas
what is new york baby what's new york
baby
sandwiches chess baby
why is it new york why's your foot job
uh
because people walk everywhere least
amount of sandals because nobody wants
to walk around new york with sandals
because your feet get so [ __ ] dirty
so we don't get to see feet that much
it's like anal and morocco exactly right
you only get to do that within your
family
but outside of that it's foot and if you
look at california the most is
asian
[Laughter]
why is that because there's a lot of
them over there of course yeah yeah
so they're skewing the search yeah look
at louisiana yeah why is it naked naked
women
they're always
that's just mardi gras they're not even
watching porn they're just celebrating
florida's magazines
who is harley quinn
that's the joker robbie and suicide is
so funny that's an entire topic
where is that i don't know what state
that is
or something maine is fisting
those [ __ ] weirdos
you [ __ ] weirdos dude
fisting wow that is nuts
what trans where where where's uh
maryland maryland yup that's that dc
[ __ ] oh that's that dc [ __ ]
maryland there you go that's new jersey
come on new jersey
now that makes sense for them tough ass
italian women on real housewives like
cursing at their husbands on a goddamn
time yo furry mississippi's furry yep
that's crazy okay
is pantyhose yo morning sex can someone
explain this yeah they don't the sun
doesn't cause the sun doesn't say that
that's a good ass point it's just
morning sex they're just looking for
daytime [ __ ] yeah they need to see
light yeah
look at idaho where's idaho huge boobs
no giant tess oh oh amazon it's giant
tess that's idaho
son i'm still trying to figure out what
state is harley quinn bruh she's killing
me yo can you just thank god
oh iowa
harley quinn oh no michigan's blow job
where does it say harley quinn right
there
oh wow
lesbian yoga iowa wisconsin wisconsin yo
quickie oh that's how cold it is up
there blow job north dakota that's
michigan
yeah what what is that [ __ ] oh yeah
301 oh uh joi three on one
three on one
what joy no i don't know no three on one
wait where is that woody's oh it's j.o.i
what the [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] i don't even know what that
means that's a little wild yeah
looking forward to you yo that's just
mag
that's the news they just like the news
down there
i mean some of this is crazy
oh man
texas loves everything built hand job i
can't even trust you
who looks at hand job porn what cucks
are you talking what is tripping what
where's that where's vermont up at the
yo
who is penis pump
no that's the next level loser [ __ ] son
you watch this south carolina's penis
pump yo sex toy is new hampshire
yeah vibrator is
is that atlanta
no no no
no no big ass
south
is
that's some loser [ __ ] right there dude
oh north carolina's penis pump yeah yo
bbw was that west virginia big black
woman that's west virginia bro let's go
oh yeah that makes a beautiful woman big
oh just all fat girls count as a bbw
okay natural tits
latinos texas that makes so much sense
though fire dog
fire twerking i guess that's vegas yeah
this is getting tips on their [ __ ]
job mormon porn that's unbelievable what
is mormon porn i don't know coffee
drinking is going to a starbucks
yeah anal cream pie
oh that's kind of fire what is joi
can you google that real quick let's do
a little google search if you had to
guess
what is your guess for what joi is
jerk off inside
oh you're close what is it
jerk off instructions
what do these need instructions bruh bro
what seattle right we got to give up
that state i don't know yeah
we're going to send you up there that's
crazy is that are i mean are any of
these surprising
all the weird ones are kind of
surprising yeah yeah all of them yeah
cartoon i don't like new york's foot job
though i love that that makes sense
yeah i love thick latina but that's
that's also a fire it's if his foot job
yo time spent per
visit philippines killing them yeah the
philippines be not coming
[ __ ] losers get a job to the stories
brothers
[ __ ] to do what are we at we're right
here nine minutes 44 middle of the pack
as always who's the quickest
russia they got [ __ ] to do nah they
ended up being cut off
let me figure that out time spent by
state wyoming nothing to do i'm telling
you it makes sense
short is bet new york dumb low see i
told you you got [ __ ] to do connecticut
then [ __ ] are rich brother
things to do